new report from Fox News details the
extent of New York's unused hospital
beds of ventilators while laying out
wide-ranging mismanagement and waste and
as we told you a New York State Director
puts still contagious coronavirus
patients into nursing homes thankfully
finally New York is abandoning the
stupidity and some of the dumb awful
parts of that policy on top of putting
corona koban 19 patients at nursing
homes when they had a hospital ship
converted for kovat patients 3,000 bed
hospital manned by somebody else waiting
to help them that they barely used
182 patients that's all that ever went
on board the Navy hospital ship Comfort
Javits Center was never halfway full
New York's health commissioner Howard
Zucker continues to come under fire New
York Post editorial board dubbing him
dr. death
in with reaction former New York City
Mayor Rudy Giuliani they didn't buy the
ventilators in the city they didn't buy
him in the state that their own health
commissions said they would need peak
week and him buy him this after 9/11
they they literally were telling us
March 2nd DeBlasio saying go out on the
town March 10th it's saviors it's okay
March 2nd
Governor Cuomo we we're arrogant New
Yorkers and it's not gonna happen in New
York and we're prepared they weren't
prepared Donald Trump saved their
backsides all that said then they put
the order to send the sickest people
into nursing homes screaming we can't
care for these people when they had the
beds Donald Trump built and man for them
mr. mayor I don't know what to say about
this 25% of the elderly population is
that represents the deaths here well
Shawn this would be an example of the
left hand not knowing what the right
hand is doing the mayor and the governor
as far as I could tell met for the first
time about two days ago well that's it I
mean that's just horrible because the
only way you can manage something like
this is as a unit from the moment 9/11
happened in fact from the moment that I
escaped from the
police that we were trapped I called the
governor and governor Pataki and I were
partners for the next three months we
had our staff meetings together we made
our decisions together this whole idea
that their bodies a couple of dozen
bodies were discovered you know outside
of a funeral home rotting for two or
three weeks one of the first things we
anticipated with a number of body bags
and funeral directors we would need and
then we found out we wouldn't need many
because unfortunately the bodies
disintegrated so then we immediately
began a DNA situation but we had
prepared for this we had had at least
eight or ten drills over the last six
seven years to prepare for tragedies and
for of crises and for anthrax and for
sarin gas I I would I would wonder how
many how many such preparations DeBlasio
did in its time as mayor